everything feels very muted in this
video almost everything hello my name is
grace helbig if you did not know now you
know your life is different now I don't
know if that's it gonna be thing the one
thing I am consistent about is how
unsure I feel about that being a phrase
that repeats itself in all of my videos
yeah I've been working on some
impressions recently and here's my
impression of most news murder murder
fear murdered destruction murder murder
fear murder disaster murder natural
disaster caused by something you know
you were doing wrong murder murder
potential murder murder fear disaster
murder this doesn't hurt you we think
that every murder murder continued
another migratory opossum order Thank
You Lorne Michaels if you want me to
join the cast of SNL I can do two
impressions the news and apparently a
slightly less feminine-looking Gandalf I
think the news is so depressing that I
decided to start a segment on this
YouTube channel called the muses and
which I just tell you about some good
news that I've acquired from the
internet and other sources hearsay she's
fun so let's get into some good news
good news is a trust fall challenge is a
thing that's happening I don't have
you've seen all the videos of it but
it's a new challenge where kids just
randomly go up to their friends and
Trust fall onto them to see if their
friends catch them or not the good news
is this is a very efficient way to find
out who is your real friend you don't
need to go the standard route of having
some sort of really terrible long
drawn-out breakup or unexpected terminal
illness to find out who your true
friends are instead just try and trust
fall on them when they least expect good
news is Kelly Ripa apparently is being
very passive-aggressive and that's fun
to see just photographed wearing a
jacket that says freedom on it and
everyone thinks that this is a
passive-aggressive dig at Michael
strands leaving their talk-show amidst
all this controversy but I think that
this is too
her showing her love for my favorite
song on lemonade other good news is that
Minnie Driver barely nothing
passive-aggressive at all I read a story
this week that Ginny neighbor don't get
along and the construction that he's
doing on his house is causing her such
anger that I guess she threw baby
bottles full of black paint at his house
creative artistic aggressive amazing I
appreciate it there's some good news I
like this little while ago you can add
emojis to your tweets using your actual
desktop keyboard biting the keys could
convince pace that's great news here's
some good news
audible.com still likes me enough to
give you guys a link to download
audiobook Auto calm has over 250,000
audiobooks on their website including
but not limited to my two books rice and
style the art of pretending you have it
and graces guide the art of pretending
to be a grown-up now if you go to
audible.com slash brace you can download
your first audio book for free and like
John Lennon once said there's no better
money than free money audible.com slash
Grace well there's a ton of self-help
book downloads on here I deal with
difficult people which brings me to my
next good news good news is
Massachusetts senator and outspoken
human female Elizabeth Warren is
dominating Twitter in the best way
possible she is so wonderful and I very
much enjoy her tweets here are just a
few of my favorite treats from Elizabeth
Warren potential future vice president I
wish real Donald Trump lied his way
through the primaries without being held
accountable
that's over no real Donald Trump your
racism sexism and xenophobia doesn't
drive me nuts it makes me sick and I'm
not alone we get it real Donald Trump
when a woman stands up to you you're
going to call or a basket case hormonal
ugly real Donald Trump your policies are
dangerous your words or reckless your
record is embarrassing and your free
ride is over that's some damn good news
here's some good news uh Julia Roberts
walked the red car
for her film premiere in Cannes France
barefoot I don't want to even read the
story I don't want to know what the
context is I just liked that it happened
I just hope that this starts to trend
can we start this trend every person out
there the book that it should like yeah
okay so good news SIA is amazing
marriages it's good news I can steps on
my arm not having a heart attack or
stroke there's some good news my
birthday I found out is national corned
beef hash day
I'm refinery29 I think you can find out
the national food holiday of your
birthday important for your tinder
profiles especially there's some good
news I just read this headline and at
knitting all spots Serena Williams a
former dog food and instantly regretted
it okay not good news for Serena
Williams obviously but we should just
curious me we've all been there we've
all been there I hope she's okay I know
I'm okay for having read that you're
some good news apparently you can freeze
ice faster if you put boiling hot water
in your ice tray rather than cold water
and I tested this about half hour 40
minutes ago
I've put an ice tray in my freezer half
with hot water and half the cold water
let's go see how it did oh my god okay
good news is I did not leave the ice in
the freezer long enough to make any
actual conclusions it's all water so
this is why we don't do science on this
channel okay I think that's all the good
news that I can handle for right now I
hope that this puts you in a slightly
better mood than normal news desk
are you more informed debatable but are
you happier also debatable I know I feel
good get off grace feels great thank you
guys so much for watching if you enjoyed
this video please subscribe because
that's an easy way for you to stay
connected to me without me trying to
like hunt you down it would be good for
both of us I think I'll leave a comment
down below letting me know some good
news that you've heard recently and let
me know if you want me to continue
making this series videos good news is
we start off pretty medium with this
series so it can only hopefully get
better from here maybe possibly no
definite good news is
there's no deafness in all of life we
could all die tomorrow
I don't know oh hey trust fall